[Musik]
hallo zusammen
in diesem video zeige ich euch wie ihr
in unter 30 minuten ein tortenboden
hinkriegt wir benötigen 3 130 gramm
zucker 125 gramm mehl drei esslöffel
warmes wasser und ein teelöffel
backpulver die eier gebe ich mit drei
esslöffel wasser in wein mixa und
schlage das trikot sechs minuten dann
cremig
[Musik]
dann wird noch der zucker untergerührt
zu guter letzt werden die trockenen foto
hinter kurven dafür heimische ich
backpulver mit mehl und gäbe dass in
einem schwung rein und lassen das einmal
ganz kurz unterrühren
[Musik]
windberg fertig und kanton in einer 26
cm springform geführt werden
[Musik]
der tortenboden wieder 280 grad ober
unterhitze für 20 minuten gebacken
dieser tortenboden eignet sich perfekt
für einen ofen kochen oder ihr könnt ihn
aber auch mit sahne füllen und wenn ihr
einen aufwendigeren bizkit boden haben
möchtet dann könnt ihr euch gerne das
eingesetzte video anschauen